why's women
need motivation what's the top 10 with
believe nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something greater
inside you as well you've got Michael
Jordan level talent at something so get
ready to commit fully make money and
master sales with Dan Pena and my take
on his top ten rules a successful him
eight to give you the belief that you
need
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one commit fully when Josh was uh he had
a sixty hour a week job and he was doing
kill a 70 hours a week that doesn't give
him much room for sleep does it but you
say well he was 1718 you know needs 15
17 18 you will already we already got a
reason why he you can't work 130 40
hours a week that you need sleep
he cut back the three hours a night's
sleep the guy who just listened to and
then he couldn't take it he only lasted
a few weeks at three hours a night's
sleep and so he had to go back to four
hours when you know it's like when you
were in lust with that person you know
you wanted a call knife in the toilet in
the car in the closet or your app when
you when you figure out that every hour
you sleep you're not making money you'll
never sleep again
rule number two focus on making money
now money's not everything it's the only
thing anybody keeps track of but it's
not everything but for those of you who
want to save the world
go find a product an idea that will
change a billion lives and by definition
one you'll save the world and two you'll
be a billionaire because you see gates
and Buffett and a number of the
Illuminati's that have made a lot a lot
of money in current day they've made a
lot of money now they're trying to save
the world
Bill Gates wasn't running around with a
placard as they say in this country
around the embassy about save the
rainforests when it was 17 18 20 years
old and we have some save the world guys
in the gut in the audience and we have
save the world guys in every audience
rule number three master sales our
children finish undergraduate school and
they both work before they went on to
graduate school I told both Kelly and
Derek makes 300 phone calls a day and
you'll lead the nation in sales or in
anything you do 300 cold calls a day and
that's getting through to somebody not
leaving a message web event and they
both did you cannot even if you're a
[ __ ] like you guys if you made 300
legitimate cold calls you'll make a
million dollars a year no problem and
that's not a lot of money and I say that
be grudgingly but to most people it is
that's 12 that's 1,500 cold calls a week
that's 6,000 cold calls a month that's
72,000 cold calls a year if you can't
make a million are you ought to kill
yourself metaphorically speaking
number four be selfish I tell the kids
you're gonna hear something here that
you not hear you haven't heard what
going up I want you to be more selfish
to fulfill your dreams and for those
people that are getting in the way of
your dreams the don't be more selfish to
them just extract them from your life
mmm it's a lot easier and my first wife
or what my current wife for Oh for many
years we're here to tell you they'd say
we worship the ground and walks on but
nobody loves Dan more than Dan mm-hmm
my love for my husband is transitory
compared to his love for himself nobody
loves me more than me and that's how you
be the best husband the best student the
best father the best brother the best
grandchild the best citizen in my
judgment is love of yourself of course
that's self-esteem that's
self-confidence also if you want to have
more confidence check out my 254 series
they're free the links to join are in
the description below you want people
with a like mind and that are better
than you smarter than you more
intelligent than you to get on your bus
but knowing guys know initially upfront
you have to try you have to swing at the
plate a kid like you if you had to keep
track of seven days a week 24 hours a
day what you do rule number five have a
tough skin when you think about what
other people think say about you cetera
but we really haven't dwelled on because
it is a waste of time
how much time you waste worrying and of
course you worry because you have thin
skin the car Adenauer the former mayor
of Berlin said the thick skin was a gift
from God
thick skin he was a politician very
successful politician and the Sally
calls me Rhino skin because it takes
extrude I mean I can't remember the last
time that somebody said something that
well I can't ever remember since I'm a
kid somebody Saints them that hurt me
I mean hurt my feelings i I just I think
back about it you know you know I can't
I can't remember and I'm sure everybody
in this room can remember somebody
saying something about them that hurt
your feelings I can't remember and you
can remember because I just you know I
wasn't raised that way
rule number six follow your heart if you
want but go back how much to do what
well I don't know I want to become
wealthy well I mean it's easier to
become wealthy here than in Romania
although we have Romanian mentees
millionaires we do but it's harder here
at seton um it's not easy easy
but it lissa way nia hungry Romania
those countries that's harder oh the
best deal in 25 years was just done by
one of my Hungarian mentees and he just
did the second best deal in 25 years on
top of that deal and he's a little Peter
if you're listening I mean I mean he
didn't have enough self-confidence to
brush his own teeth I mean and now he's
a wealthy guy on the cover of Hungarian
business and he did it without paying
one bribe and that's a big deal know
that part of the world so but I mean you
got to follow your heart I don't mean a
lovey good way for your mom I mean you
got to follow your heart because in 25
years from now your mother's going to be
dead and you're gonna be regret that you
spend any time with her yeah I'm in the
regret minimization business what are
you going to tell your grandkids during
the greatest transformation of wealth
and they history the planet what were
you doing other than having a thumb up
your ass rule number seven be a firm
leader be firm but fair but firm because
people appreciate their the kids don't
lack ingenuity what they lack is
leadership and now being a firm leader
it's considered politically incorrect
showing tough love they forget the tough
part remember the love part hope you
recommend a tough-minded management
correct job at and yet still a very
relevant book it is Jo baton was the
mentor of Ross Perot a billionaire back
in the day and he also wrote a little
bit of my principles I think yeah that's
like my life in my principle yeah not
many people read it because I don't have
very poor now no any also wrote a book
to find a leadership yeah and those are
the only two books you need on
management and leadership rule number
eight be hard our kids were here right
now my daughter would say Jesus guy
the world is stepdad for another reason
though why anybody would want to be
raised by you you have no idea what it
was to be your child I'm sure I don't I
don't and my daughter as I think I
mentioned yesterday my dad treats
everybody the same like and I'm hard and
hard works world-class coaches are hard
we have a blog on the hall of fame my
most successful mentees he says I
haven't been beat this hard since I was
the number two guy on the Austrian ski
team arguably one of the best ski teams
in the world and then he blew out his
knee and his coach used to beat him I
mean physically beat him now I can't get
away with that anymore but the most even
needed a beat and growing up you just
did and most of you your parents your
parents weren't weren't trained to
produce high-performance kids you and I
both know it you and I both know it
we've had hut we've had grandfather's
daughters granddaughters we've had sons
and fathers in the seminar room and when
you ask the grandfather I did the best
we know now ask the mother you don't
know what you don't know ask the kid
yeah you don't know what your kids will
you think about you I do
I get their emails most of your kids are
embarrassed by you
in some cases I'm sorry to say ashamed
of you
rule number nine getting the right
business I'm 31 I will my own business
we make about a hundred and twenty grand
a year give or take which i think is
very low I have another idea I might I
might do which I think could make maybe
a million but am I just shy just abort
everything and just most of you that
have businesses in the room if you go
home and turn the key does everybody
understand that close them down don't
open up Monday I can say that I don't
even have to look at your numbers turn
the key adios something new because most
of you are living quiet lives of
desperation
most of you are living hand-to-mouth
paycheck to paycheck that's a hell of an
existence I used to be there believe me
I know what that feels like you know and
but if you're not in a big margin
low-hanging fruits if you're not in the
new economy if you're not in health care
if you're not in telco if you're not in
cybersecurity if you're not in radiology
if you're not in the things that
building infrastructure building roads
building bridges you're just humans what
book metaphorically you might as well
just blow your brains out because Sally
she says goddamn it Danny said remember
what the lawyers told us so no the
lawyers you know and rule number ten the
last time before a very special bonus
clip is improve your communication
skills people were the best
communication skills do best at this and
most of your communications go suck most
of the ditch retards not Ameen [ __ ]
in that sense retards watching this in
YouTube have no communication skills at
one time I had piss-poor communication
skills they used to throw plates at me
when I talk go to a Rotary Club to give
us
can you miss you place at me your
feelings would be hurt now I've got a
special bonus tip from Dan on how to
step up that I think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching a video to taking
action here we go question number 1
where do you need to improve your
communication skills number two how can
you be a more firm leader and number
three where do you just need to follow
your heart and if you're gonna take some
immediate action after watching this
video give me a hashtag believe down in
the comments as well most of the people
managing money wealth today have never
seen a bad market they went around in 87
I have but all of the guys that have are
dead got dementia are not interested
anymore there are going to be more
opportunities when everything falls this
but it takes it takes balls I mean you
got to step in and you may have to put
your whole net worth on the line and
then because you stopped playing to win
and you start playing not to lose I've
been there
if you want more day in pain you check
that the top-50 rules video I made on
him the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
Adolf Hitler might be the highest
performance guy that ever was born on
the planet when you decide that you
really want to invoke permanent change